en fait dans les années 60- 70 euh le
système criminel et notamment le système
mafieux qui est beaucoup moins développé
hein parce que nous en France tout est
mafieux mais en fait c'est pas vrai hein
les mafias il y en a relativement peu
elles sont très puissantes mais en
France on a du crime organisé euh euh
qui avait tenté d'avoir des relations
avec la mafia mais qui en a relativement
peu euh dans la réalité le système était
très sectorisé chacun avait sa petite
spécialité et puis
après l'apparition de l'andrangetta et
de la Camora ça a tout changé il y a eu
une modernisation massive et donc tout
le monde fait tout il n'y a plus de
spécialité plus par exemple vous prenez
les centres de
prostitution le long de la frontière
espagnole ce sont des centres de
prostitution et de distribution de stup
désormais on est
multiservice les réseaux de blanche
d'argent à 90% servent à la frte fiscale
qu'on appelle l'optimisation fiscale dès
lors que vous avez un truc offshore
quelque part il est illégal dangereux et
devrait être interdit point ça ne sert
qu'à la fraude sur ces tuyaux se
branche plein d'autres choses le
blanchiment la
rétrocommission l'argent du terrorisme
c'est très petit évidemment l'argent des
stupes al l'argent d stup c'est estimé à
vue de nez tout compris trafic estupe 5
% du PIB mondial et 20 à 25 % des dépôts
et à peu près 70 % 50 à 70
% des offshore cumulativement pas en
rythme anuel parce que c'est assez
difficile d'en faire quelque chose
puisque la lutte antiblanchivement
fonctionne quand même plus ou moins bien
plus ou moins bien parce que les cryptos
ont créé un nouvel espace
de liberté au blanchiment mais
aujourd'hui tout le monde fait tout en
fait pour des raisons que vous avez
parfaitement indiqué c'est le gain et
donc si je peux faire ça et en même
temps faire autre chose et rapporter
plus à la fin pourquoi pas et nous avons
d'aujourd'hui une intégration en fait le
crime et notamment le trafic de stup
c'est le modèle le plus abouti de
l'économie de marché intégration
verticale intégration horizontale
investissement dans la recherche et
dével
développement des zones de
chalandise petit incentive pour le petit
personnel seule la gestion de la
concurrence est plus définitive que dans
le commerce traditionnel